okay well either way this is my
opportunity to see you before things get
too crazy
Caitlyn and this is Ashley
this is my wife Maggie
I'm glad you're here today
yeah yeah
that makes my heart Happy so great
and Caitlyn and I got coffee this would
have been a while back four months maybe
six months something yeah
yeah it's been a while but
no
Louisiana
East Texas
[Music]
you're a doppelganger to someone else
that I know I get that with a lot
yes I just have that kind of face you do
you do I feel like we know each other in
another life we were best friends
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah she's
she's great she's a great gal so yeah I
hope you all can get to know her in the
in the future and yeah so well
excited good I'm glad I'm so glad you're
here and and pushing through I know it's
like you know
re-engaging church just sort of like
okay deep breaths here we are
it's okay
[Music]
yeah yeah
here we are it's great
yeah
I had a very deep conversation with my
wife oh yes I think you just alluded to
it maybe in a Facebook message or like a
conversation you needed to have and
working wow
yeah
[Music]
wow that's awesome maybe who knows how
even it contributed to you being able to
like take a step forward and like even
be here today so
it's kind of really
yeah yeah
[Music]
well I hope so I hope so
but no pressure too you just engage at
the pace you need to and you know if
there's any point you're kind of like oh
this is triggering me or what you know
feel free to take a step out I won't be
offended
so yeah all right
awesome awesome well I'm glad you're
here and yeah thanks I know just
I don't think so I mean I don't know
it's like I just my tummy just felt
rumbly like last night and this morning
and I was kind of like oh I never like
threw up or anything but I just I don't
know and then kind of just a little
de-energized like not quite myself so
but I'm not terrible like not dead
ridden or anything but
yeah
anyway
all right well it's great to meet you
Ashley yeah hey what's up here I'll just
give you Knuckles since I'm not feeling
good that's okay um have you met Caitlin
and Ashley this is Caleb
love you nice to meet you Ashley nice to
meet you they're in a Rowlett
[Music]
uh Mariners Park was named
it's Karen here
Gary have you seen your wife
oh she did
oh so I'm doing it then
oh Don's doing it okay
great all right oh there he is all right
awesome
hey it's good
welcome to the table hope everyone is
doing well
good evening and we have here at this
weird time random time that we don't
normally meet at thank you for being
very flexible and being able to get here
um at four o'clock we don't normally do
this at four o'clock for those of you
who are our regulars obviously you know
that but if you're visiting just let you
know that this is not a normal time for
us uh five o'clock is our normal Sunday
weekly thing but because of some social
events that might be taking place later
on
um made some adjustments so thank you
for guys for all being flexible with
that just a couple quick announcements
um so uh for if you're 20 something they
are they are doing their monthly
um
a small group wrench that's going to be
happening so it's going to be on
Saturday February the 18th
um and so it's going to be fun like
games and just get to know your
activities and things like that that's
something you're interested in if you
wouldn't mind just uh put your name on
the visitor card we'll just make sure
the leaders get that information they
reach out to you directly about that the
other thing Ash Wednesday is coming up
can't believe Easter is around the
corner
crazy but Ash Wednesday is coming up and
we're going to be doing a service with
Pleasant Valley
um it's going to be on February the 22nd
it's going to be in the evening 7 P.M
um I will say personally I have not done
had a lot of experience with anything
dealing with lent but I have really
enjoyed especially last year's service
it's been was has been very powerful
that's something you're not that's new
to you as well make sure to check it out
it's it's it's a very powerful event
I've I still remember from the one from
last year is amazing
So within with all these announcements
over we're gonna get started with
worship I want to start us off with a
prayer
Lord thank you so much for bringing us
all together thank you for this time
this space the ability to come and
worship
um I pray that you open up our hearts
and Minds to the message and to the
words that you're going to be sharing
with us today in Christ and I pray amen
thanks Don
what's this one okay if you guys want to
stand with us we're going to jump in
with brighter days Josh is going to
leave this one for us so you guys sing
it with us if you know it and I hope
these words give you some hope if you're
in a dark space I hope that they give
you a little bit of light at the end of
the tunnel
[Music]
foreign
S I know there's gonna be some brighter
days
I know there's gonna be some brighter
oh ashes fall like burning dreams
oh never live through times like these
oh if you're trying hard to breathe in
the dark
in the dark
I know there's gonna be some brighter
days
I swear that love will find you in your
pain
of life in my veins I know there's gonna
be some brighter days
I know there's gonna be some Brighter
Day
oh if your screams don't make us make a
sound
oh if your walls are crashing down
oh if your heart just cries too loud all
the time
all the time
[Applause]
I know there's gonna be some brighter
days
I swear that love will find you in your
pain
I feel
I feel like the beating of life in my
veins I know there's gonna be some
brighter days
I know there's gonna be some brighter
days
[Music]
there's gonna be some brighter days I
swear that love will find you in your
pain
I feel it in me like the beating of life
in my veins
I know there's gonna be some brighter
days
I swear that love will find you in your
pain
I feel it in me like the beating of life
in my veins I know there's gonna be some
brighter days I know there's gonna be
some brighter days
I know there's gonna be some Brighter
Day
[Music]
all right kiddos you can head to class
so we're gonna move into our prayers of
the people which is just a time that
we're going to read something together
as a community and then there'll be
space for us to share names and
situations out loud that we are wanting
to pray for also if you are online
you can type in the comments names or
situations that you want us to pray for
as well
so let's read this together
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us we
hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence amen
[Music]
foreign
to bury it along
and I hear your invitation
[Music]
to let it all go yeah I see it now I'm
laying it down and I know that I need
you I'll run to the father or fall into
Grace I'm done with the hiding no reason
to wait my heart needs to serve
my soul needs a friend so I run to the
father again and again and again
[Music]
should
the price for my heart
and I don't have a contest
[Music]
for that kind of love I don't understand
it can't comprehend all I know is that
we do run to the father I fall into
Grace
done with the hearty no reason to wake
my heart needs a surgeon my soul needs a
friend so I run to the father again and
again and again and again
[Music]
and again
worlds
[Music]
my heart has been in your
size long before my
first breath running into your
arms
[Music]
deep in my chest your mercy is
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
again and again
[Music]
and again
and I need you so much closer
I need you so much closer
[Music]
sing with me come on
come on
[Music]
so come on
come on
[Music]
the way
the truth
[Music]
and I believe you are the way
the true
I believe you are
New Horizons
and I've Set On You
me here
with mercies that are new
all my fears and doubts
they can all come to because they can't
stay long when I'm here
[Music]
today with Mercies
because they can't stay long when I'm
here with you
[Music]
through every battle
through every heartbreak
through every circumstance
and I believe that you are my Fortress
you are my portion
you are my Hiding Place
[Music]
the truth
never
[Music]
through every blessing
through every promise
for every breath I take
I believe that you are provided
and you are protected
you are the one I love yeah
the truth
never believe you are the way
I believe you are and it's a New Horizon
and I'm set on you and you meet me here
today with mercies
and doubts
they can all come too because they can't
stay long when I'm here with you and
it's a New Horizon
and I'm set on you
you beat me here today with mercies that
are new and all my fears and doubts
they can all come too because they can't
stay long when I'm here with you
[Music]
foreign
needs a new horizon
and I'm sit on you
and you meet me here today with mercies
that are new
nude all my fears and doubts
that they can all come too because they
can't stay long
when I'm here with you
thank you
[Music]
God would we feel you here with us
whatever it is that we've been through
this week whatever we're carrying into
this space would we feel you here with
us in US
breath in our lungs
blood in our veins
you are present
You Are Holy
[Music]
and your love is for us
and we try God to let you in
to find you in our broken places
in our Beautiful Moments God would we
find you there
right in the midst of it
you are good
you are constant
you are faithful
would we find you close tonight
foreign
thank you for your love
thank you for a community that reminds
us
that when we feel isolated and alone
that we are not alone
[Music]
thank you for this space that we share
would it continue to draw us
towards your heart
would we be that for each other
we love you Jesus
[Music]
thank you for these moments together
it's in your name we pray
amen
would you guys turn to the people around
you and
say hello give them a hug make them feel
welcome and then Brett will get us
started thank you guys
all right oh
well good evening
grace and peace it's so good to be with
you all and
um that was a beautiful time in in the
Lord's presence it's really good good to
worship good to um just re-center on
Christ and um and his love for us
there's something really really
wonderful about that so I want to also
extend that welcome to those join us
online love y'all lots you're not
forgotten and um anyone who's new with
us thanks for being here tonight so
um we are in this is part four in our
series titled rooted grounded
discipleship we thought
um it would be just kind of wise like
here at the beginning of the year to
walk through some of the just like the
basics of following Jesus so it's a very
like um kind of practical series uh you
know on like how to live because at the
end of the day
um while Christian faith of course has
like certain
um doctrines or ideas and such that are
um you know like East Central I'm
thinking of you know whether it's ideas
about Christ or the Trinity or the
resurrection you know like all this
matters uh but at the end of the day uh
Christianity it must be something we
live right something we do in fact
um and not and even by the doing I'm
talking about like relating well
learning to love well because if we're
not doing that like what are we doing
and in fact uh the Apostle Paul he
talked about this in um First
Corinthians uh 13 where he described
like how he could do sort of all these
um more spiritual things to kind of
paraphrase he's basically like look I
could like have all the theological
knowledge uh I could uh speak in the
tongues of of normal human beings and of
angels I could like reveal theological
Mysteries to people and be like aha
you've never thought of it this way you
know like he's like and he just goes on
and on with all these things like he
could do and be like basically like the
most
spiritual uh person or at least that we
would externally think like whoa wow
they that person they really got
together they know they know all the
things you know uh and he said but if I
don't have love
what is it
remember
nothing
that was his word just nothing at all
it's like it's just mist
and mystification just nothing everyone
around him might have thought oh it's a
something it's just oh yeah he she you
know like oh there there really is
something
uh nope not without love so uh so really
this kind of driving the series has been
what would it mean to
um learn to live in that love to express
it uh so it's been you know very very
practical as we've uh talked about like
last week was
um we'll start two weeks ago was how to
uh pray last week was how to read like
scripture uh next week we're going to be
talking about how to live in the
presence of God in each moment but
tonight to the title of my message is
how to fight
I like this title how to fight uh now
I'm not talking about you know like I
don't know weird MMA style or something
uh I'm not yeah I'm not going there but
uh really this is you know what to do
when we find ourselves um in the midst
of relational conflict and uh struggle
which is really you know just they had a
fight I mean some of the reason I word
it like this is because if you've been
here you know I've been wording each
sermon like how to and then fill in the
blank with one word so you know I
couldn't say like how to make peace it's
like well that doesn't too many words so
I said how to fight but really I am
asking how do we work towards peace in
the midst of it uh as as Paul he talks
about in Romans 12 18. uh he reminds us
as if it is possible as far as it
depends on you
live at peace with everyone
and then again second Corinthians
chapter 5 verses 18 through 19 he says
all this is from God who reconciled us
to himself through Christ and gave us
the ministry of reconciliation that God
was reconciling the world to himself in
Christ not counting people's sins
against him he has committed to us the
message of reconciliation in other words
uh Christians like we're the peace
people
where there were the reconciling people
this is and and why why is that because
God in Christ has reconciled healed the
relationship between us and God and then
we're like sent out into the world right
to live and not to be people who are
constantly stirring up the strife and
dissension although if you looked at a
lot of Christians posts online and such
you might never guessed that but you
know like that's not our goal we're
we're the reconciliation
um kind of people or the peace people
so I'm kind of in keeping with a series
I've been thinking the last few weeks
like okay so like what would it mean to
fight well to relate in the midst of
conflict well and and how would we do
that in like a kind of a practical way
because I wouldn't yeah I wanted to give
you something that is like this we can
do this we can change when we're in the
midst of of conflict so of course I mean
this is a big topic we could talk about
like a hundred things but tonight we're
just going to focus in on one thing this
is a one-point sermon and uh the passage
is from uh that I want to draw from
tonight heavily is the words of Christ
in Matthew chapter seven uh where Christ
said these these famous words do not
judge
has three very powerful words isn't it
do not judge
or you too will be judged for in the
same way you judge others you will be
judged and with the measure you used it
will be measured to you and he gives
this famous metaphor why do you look at
the at the speck of sawdust in your
brother's eye and pay no attention to
the plank in your own I think there's
something about often we can see in
others the thing where we often struggle
with ourselves
you know and there's like this tendency
to like call it out you know but why can
you see it so clearly because it's like
been your struggle you know in fact
maybe they're even struggling with it
less than you
and yeah I mean at least that's the
analogy right it's like the spec of saw
about dust in their eye the plank of
wood in our own and we're like oh my
gosh how could you you know
uh he continues how can you say to your
brother let me take the speck out of
your eye when all the time there's a
plank in your own eye you hypocrite
first take the the plank out of your own
eye then you'll see clearly to remove
the speck from your brother's eye now
of course as I kind of alluded to the
way most folks interpret this passage is
uh is in the in the context of like
another's you know either real or
imagined like you know thin they're
they're struggle they're they're
shortcoming uh that's the speck of
sawdust right um but in keeping with our
theme tonight I wanted to kind of read
this passage in maybe a little bit of a
fresh way I wanted to bring our topic of
um you know relational
conflict and being in the midst of that
and kind of bring those
um eyes to to this passage because I
think
um it's quite easy to
not judge when the the wrongdoing is
against other people
but it becomes of course so much harder
when it's a wrong done against who
yes against us against me like then it's
like oh no you did not right like in
other words we would say maybe we've
even said something like oh there's just
like I would never judge someone I'm not
a judgey like there's not a judgmental
bone in my body
you ever heard someone said not a
judgmental mode of my body and that can
be true like you see them they hurt them
and you're like hey I'm not gonna jump
or judge you know uh but oh and all of a
sudden it's done to us or send to the
people we love oh don't you like all of
a sudden we are lawyer judge and jury
all wrapped up in a one
and we're like coming after them right
this is and yet it's in that moment that
Christ's words ring in our ears do not
judge
so this I guess naturally is the
question so what does it mean to judge
exactly
um again the way we commonly interpret I
think would be to say something like
well
to not judge is to not say something is
wrong
you know like because that's when people
say you're judging right if you're like
hey that thing you did that was wrong
and they say how dare you judge me you
know so um
but I've been thinking how it's true
that like there are people in my life
who could speak very hard truths to me
sometimes truths uh I didn't want to
hear and yet I did not feel judged by
them have you ever had this experience
like in other words it seems like
there's some difference between
speaking the truth in love
and getting judgy
you know like getting on our high horse
and really and just you know that spirit
that vibe that comes over us or others
and just like oh gosh it's that
judgmental Spirit right so I've been um
yeah kind of asking myself like what
would it what's the difference there so
here's um here's kind of our big idea
for tonight to judge another person is
to Simply assume the worst about their
heart and their motives
like if that's where the judgmental
spirit that Vibe starts coming out
jumping out
um maybe another way to word it is
um it is to weave
a wildly creative
and mostly wrong story about why they
did what they did
or why they have become who they have
become
you might say it is to kind of adopt the
gods eye view of the world and that
person
a God's eye view of course that we don't
actually have do we because we're not
Gods we're not God
um it's and it's fascinating though like
what Master storytellers all right I'm
gonna put it on you all I'll just say
what a master Storyteller I become
when I'm offended when I'm hurt like I
will just start weaving this creative
like I mean mostly negative intense
story about why I know why they did it I
know I get it I know who they are I
don't I just start doing this uh an
example of this so some of you know I
about six months ago I started a um a
pet waste removal company
which is a fancy way of saying I pick up
dog crap
and uh I know I'm cool so um so I
started this uh like six months ago and
um just because I'm kind of I'm
part-time here at the table so you know
just like little supplemental income and
I do it on my day off and so uh it's
been a good you know it's a good gig but
I will say uh not every yard is as good
as others
um you know like I'm thinking of there's
this one yard I had an Allen and it was
like it was very small high fences small
yard overhanging tree three dogs two
bulldogs one Mastiff and then a pool in
the middle so it was like very little
green space you know and I would go back
there week after week and I'm just like
whoa I started wearing my my mask you
know like and then like nose but like I
just needed like okay all right this is
kind of you know it's intense and uh so
I do this for like a few months
servicing that you know that at home and
then we get to the month of December we
wrap up December and if you remember
um December was the unique month in that
it had five Fridays instead of four
and this led me to my first
fight
a dispute with this customer because I
sent him his invoice to you at the end
of the month and to charge him for five
Fridays because it was like five visits
and he's like what is this and I said
it's your bill and he's like well it's
different than usual
and I was like well
um that's because there's five Fridays
and you know I I charge you per visit of
course most months have four Fridays
that's why it's usually a certain amount
but this time it was you know a little
bit more because of that fifth visit and
he said well um
no no that's uh that's not how it's
gonna go because you told me it was this
amount per month and I said no I didn't
actually I said it was this amount per
visit and in a regular month this would
be your total for the four weeks but you
know how the calendar works and stuff
and he's like well the thing is you make
it up on the other month
as like you mean the months with three
Fridays that's not a thing my friend
nope uh I'm not making it up and he said
well an agreement's in agreement and oh
yeah we were texting I tried to call him
to talk this through it he wasn't
answering my phone so it was you know
firing off text that this is all just
you know and you know he sends that last
in agreement Center because I could just
tell that was his I'm done with this
conversation
and I was freaking Furious like my hands
went cold I could feel my heart like
beating out of you know you get that
just that kind of adrenaline starts
pumping I was just the Injustice of it
I'm like I'm picking up your dog crap
like dude and seriously it's like 15 and
I'm doing this every week like what is
your deal man and I'm like oh I just and
then all and then the story lines began
like it's just you know I'm like he's
evil he's an evil he's a wicked person
he's what is it what did I think he did
this for you he did this on purpose like
he knew he knew he was gonna he's gonna
play this up and so he's gonna wait till
the fifth and try to get a free visit
from me like he's played was just
waiting for the month of December to
come and go so that he could get a you
know
um
and on and so on and so forth now
eventually I realized like sort of was
he ever kind of catch yourself like this
is where I am grateful for all of the
like spiritual disciplines and things
we've been talking about you know
scripture prayer I've been I kind of
practiced for this moment you know so
like eventually I realized
took me longer than I would have liked
but I realized what's happening like
oh no no
no oh the stories the story lines
they're running through my head they're
like oh they've got me and then I became
I'm gonna date myself with this
reference but uh Gollum from Lord of the
Rings
um and I became like Gollum who kind of
has some mental issues and he's he was
going back and forth right like I was
like it's the story Brett it's a story I
was like no it's not a story it is the
truth this is about Justice I was like
no who is it you don't you don't
actually know that right you don't have
the God's eye perspective man like
you're just it's your mind your mind's
just spinning out a story I'm like no
it's not Brett I'm like just going you
know I mean I'm a mess right am I alone
in the I don't know maybe okay oh you
all know you all know
uh unraveling unraveling
to judge another person it's just to
assume that God's eye perspective it's
to assume uh the worst about their heart
and their motives it's to weave this
wildly creative and mostly wrong story
about why they have become who they have
become and why they've done what they've
done
um see because the truth is as much as
it like pains me to say it
um the truth is I don't actually know
I don't know I don't I don't know why I
I don't know maybe he really was
confused
um maybe I wasn't clear enough I sent
him screenshots of the text where I felt
like I was very clear but maybe not
maybe maybe he was going through
bankruptcy and so this you know like 15
bucks is just like the end of the world
for him or I don't
I don't I don't know of course the trick
becomes right this is sort of a silly
dispute over like fifteen dollars you
know
um the trick becomes when the things
we're going through
are like four real stuff you know like
intense
hellish kind of stuff and that's where
those storylines oh they eat Us Alive
don't they and let me tell you if you if
you have like um exhausted brain or
anxiety brain or depression brain oh
talk about the stories that like that's
like the stories on steroids you know
like just amps it up
foreign
but it seems to me that the difference
between a challenging relational
situation
and an emotional relational time bomb
is so often it's just the story We Tell
it's the narrative that we weave about
it
and but once we have that elaborate
story going once we know what a no good
so and so they are and we oh we go we
know why they do it and we know we have
the God's eye perspective and all that
once we do that what happens we fall
into the Judgment trap we've we've
adopted the role of lawyer judge and
jury so with this in mind I want to give
you kind of a creative paraphrase now
this is Brett's paraphrase of Matthew 7
1-2 thou shall not tell judgmental
stories about others or you too will be
storied
for in the same way you weave a
judgmental story about others the same
harsh narrative shall be applied to you
in other words that that same mode that
same gracelessness and patiencelessness
that like it it's like a like a
boomerang we like fling it to injure
them it's like eat this then just comes
back and uh and just hits the surface
right in the face
now just to be clear does this command
do not judge like does this mean
um never say the truth or you know never
say like well that really hurt me
because that's just a story or no
No in fact that's some one thing I like
about approaching judgment in this way
is that we can still speak the truth
right but the trick is to just say the
thing without weaving the complicated
narrative uh about it
um so I guess the key question tonight
is what would happen What would happen
if you dropped your story
what would happen
about uh that family member
uh
that church
that group of people
like what what would happen
if you let that
narrative go this can be really
challenging because honestly a lot of
this comes back to like identity
because we often frame our sense of self
in contrast to them right they're evil
and I'm good and it instills a certain
you know bolsters us
you know
and so this can be a little scary it's
like vulnerable in a way to like begin
to let our stories
go
because what if people weren't out to
get us
and what if other people like coming
back to my client I was thinking what if
he was spinning stories too I wonder
like if he thought he's like that guy's
out to get me
this guy's trying to rip me off this you
know I mean like there we are 15 miles
apart sending these texts both Furious
both spinning our our stories like all
of a sudden this opens up some space for
empathy because I start to think like
huh maybe his own mind and heart and
um desires and fears like maybe he's
getting pushed around and bullied in his
own mind just as much as I am
all right could you see that this just
might change this this would change
things would it not like in the midst of
conflict
this would change things
because you see our stories of judgment
they fuel the fires of our anger
and they dry up the Waters of our love
but if we drop the stories
if we drop the judgment
then suddenly compassion can again arise
so how do we fight
how do we make peace
drop the judgment
drop the story
so tonight as we come to the table of
the Lord as we take in the body of
Christ and the bread the blood of Christ
in the wine
I wanted to be a moment where we we come
forward and maybe there's someone you've
been thinking about
throughout this whole message maybe a
few some ones but it can be overwhelming
to maybe drop too many stories at once
maybe just start with one
and as we come forward
um tonight let's
um
let's do it with the intention to start
letting that story go and giving it to
God and allowing God to be the judge
just kind of giving that role back to
him
and um
my prayer is that God will give us the
grace to just drop those
to leave those here with him
so we practice what's called an Open
Table I mean if you're here tonight and
you want to participate in communion
then you are welcome to do that you
should know the white cups are juice and
the red cups are the real thing
they are wine it's gluten-free bread if
I were gonna do this because we're going
to just form a line right here in the
middle and then someone will hand you
the elements and you can just partake
whenever you'd like we're not going to
like lead you through you know the
partaking you just go ahead and do that
so let me welcome you to the table with
this Celtic Christian invitation this is
the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come you who have much faith
and you
who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you who have failed
come
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
I love what Brett was saying about the
God's eye view and
the song that we're going to close out
with tonight is called for everyone born
and if nothing else it is definitely a
reminder that we are all children of God
each one of us and our stories matter to
him
and I hope that as we're going into our
week that we can take that God's eye
view into each of our interactions and
in part that
that Divine love
to those around us would you guys stand
with us as we sing this last one
[Music]
for everyone
a place at the table
to everyone blind clean water
and breath
a shelter a space
a safe place for growing
for everyone
[Music]
foreign
for a woman and man
a place with the table
revising the rocks
deciding the share
with wisdom and Grace
dividing the power
woman and man
a system that's
[Music]
Justice and joy
compassion and peace
[Music]
of Justice
just to send Joy
[Music]
Justice
a place at the table
a covenant shed
oh welcoming space
a rainbow of rays of gender and colors
for gay and for straight
a chalice of Grace
[Music]
and joy
compassion and peace
[Music]
please
Justice and joy
[Music]
thank you all for uh being here thank
you worship teams as well for that
um
as we get get ready to dismiss just a
couple reminders um if you're a visitor
if you wouldn't mind just kind of
leaving a note if there is a table on
the very back as you walk out that door
where you can just kind of leave it just
we'd like to have a record of your visit
and place it in the Box as you walk out
also if you could like to support a
Ministry you can also do that also with
either by dropping your donation in that
box you're going to do that also by you
know giving online to the website and
um you know also as you're walking out
the door please make sure that you make
a connection with somebody before you
just walk out this door we just want to
make a point to note that you are seeing
that you're here that you are loved
um and that you matter to us so I
usually sit down there I will give you a
hug a high five and Shake whatever it is
that you want so if you want me to be
that person it's totally fine but make a
point to somebody this year in this room
okay because you're important you matter
as we dismiss I want to send you out
with this blessing
so you are a child of God
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day
so as you go out in your week get ahead
with this determined to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you were
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's holy spirits
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with
thank you have a good week
[Music]
foreign